prompt design allows for fast
experimentation and customization and
because you're not writing any
complicated code you don't need to be an
ml expert to get started but coming up
with prompts can be tricky and you can't
really fit all that many examples into a
prompt so what's tuning you ask well one
version you might be familiar with is
fine tuning in this scenario we take a
model that has been pre-trained on a
generic data set we make a copy of this
model and then using those learned
weights as a starting point we retrain
the model on a new domain-specific data
set if you want to learn more about
parameter efficient tuning and some of
the different methods There's a summary
paper linked below for those who are
extra curious